- He's an American actor, director,
screenwriter and producer.
He's best known for
portraying Walter White
in the AMC crime drama
series Breaking Bad.
He won four Primetime Emmy Awards for
Outstanding Lead Actor in a Drama Series.
He's Bryan Cranston and here are his
top ten rules for success.
(airplane flying)
(basketball bounce)
- I started working in
this business in 1979
so I've been doing it for 32 years.
- And you got steady work
you had lots of gigs.
- [Bryan] Yeah but but the last ten years
have been just crazy.
You know I think I think
there is truth in the
saying that you have to
know when it's your time.
And sometimes you know people go through
their awkward moments in high school
and they feel gangly
and they're not you know
they're not sure of themselves and things.
This seems to be my time.
It waited awhile but I'm glad it's here.
Well the best the best
advice for fellow actors
is this, know what your job is.
About 18 years ago I had
this cognition that I
realized I was going into auditions
trying to get a job
and that simply wasn't what I was doing.
It wasn't what I said what
I'm supposed to be doing.
An actor is supposed
to create a compelling
and interesting character
that serves the text we presented in the
environment where you audition.
And then you walk away
and that's it.
Everything else is out of your control
so don't even think of,
don't focus on that.
You're not going there to get a job
you're going there to present what you do.
You act and there it is and walk away.
There's power in that,
there's confidence in that.
And it's also saying I can only do so much
and then the decision
of who might get a job
is so out of your control
that it can really
when you analyze it it makes
no sense to hold on to that.
That to me was a breakthrough.
And once I adapted that
philosophy I never looked back
and I've never been busier in my life.
And once I grabbed onto that.
For me when I first read the
first page of the pilot script
it read just like you saw,
opened up on a beautiful
setting, red mountains,
trousers are falling from the sky.
They hit the ground,
an RV rolls over them.
Inside there's a
middle-aged man only wearing
tighty whitey underwears
and a respirator driving madly in the back
two dead bodies sliding
up and back in a sea
of fluid and glass.
Another man passed out with a respirator.
And I'm thinking what
the fuck is going on?
(laughing)
That was page one.
And it took off from there and so it
was it was one of those those rare moments
when you respond to
a piece of material so strongly
that I knew I had to get
in as fast as I could
to try to get this role.
Because the the longer I
waited I knew that every actor
in Hollywood would want to
would want to be a part of this.
And fortunately I was the one to get it.
Being able to display all that you feel
is not unlike a person wanting to
experience everything in life.
You don't always want
to be serious you don't
always want to be silly.
You want to have moments
in each, for me anyway.
And so that's why I look
for different projects
different things that take
me to more challenging areas
difficult or easy or fun, simple.
Sometimes incredibly
complex like Breaking Bad.
I had a cognitive moment
when I was 22 years old
and my brother and I
were riding motorcycles
across the country for a couple years
because we were both trying to figure out
what we wanted to do with our lives.
And it was raining, I was
on the Blue Ridge Parkway
in Virginia and it was raining hard.
So we found this little
off the beaten path
rest stop that was near a creek.
And there was a slab of
cement with four wooden posts
and a roof and a picnic table.
At this rest stop no one else was there
it was pouring rain.
So we pulled our motorcycles
and jumped up the curb
right up onto it.
It looked like we were going
to be there for a while
so we set up a camp on
this slab of cement.
And it stayed there for six days
because it didn't stop raining.
And over the six days the
only thing that really got me
through was reading a book
of a thick book of plays
it was on a motorcycle
so I couldn't take a lot.
So I had this book of plays
and I was reading Hedda Gabler
Ibsen's Hedda Gabler at the time.
And and all of a sudden it
was nightfall, it was dark.
I went what and I realized
wow that went fast
because I was so into
the reading and I thought
man that would be.
And it just went everything
lifted and I went
that's what I should do.
I loved getting lost in story
so I want to tell stories.
And I had done some acting and I thought
that's what I need to do I need to
follow that lead get involved
in something that I love to do
and hopefully become good at it.
As opposed to getting
trapped into something
I happen to be good at but I didn't love.
The success of an actor
is being willing to
go into those dark places and and
display them publicly.
We have to have that kind
of courage and vulnerability
to do that.
In high school all the way
through school I remember
trying to stay the same as everyone else.
I didn't want to stand out
everyone were wearing that
and this is what everybody else is wearing
I kind of want to I don't want
to be isolated or ostracized.
Certainly I don't want to be
embarrassed or have someone
point the finger at you,
look at that guy, you know.
What happens is that we think
that if you are vulnerable
and sensitive and open
that you'll be ridiculed.
And but as adults when we
mature what we realize is
that if you have the audacity
to display those human
honest emotions that the
opposite is what happens.
People embrace someone who is in trouble,
someone who is vulnerable,
someone who is frightened.
We they they have a tendency
to come forward and put
their emotional arms around you.
As an actor you need to to study
human behavior in some ways
in order to do that you test.
You behave a certain way
and the response to that informs you
whether it's working or not.
You know I think in ways
without me consciously
knowing it I'm always kind of
experimenting with characters
in waves and seeing how it
feels to be a certain way.
It's intriguing.
Shirley Knight was was
interesting because she got me
over a hump where I was
putting up resistance
to be you know to say you know I was
getting some work and I was starting
I was working exclusively
as an actor since I was
25 years old, 24 years old.
I've never done anything
else from that point on.
And I came to her later
and I was working as an
actor and she said, "Own it."
You know because I was putting
it, oh no, I don't want to be
I don't want to be a star
I don't want to because.
Let all that go and just again
philosophy let it come in let it come on.
Whatever's supposed to
happen happens and let it go.
You don't have to hold on
to it and hold a mirror
up to yourself but
but just let it let it flow.
And she she had a point
that was very interesting,
to to accept and embrace
an actor's arrogance.
And at at first you, arrogance oh,
I don't want to be arrogant.
And she goes, "No, but it's okay.
"Because actors like athletes
are the ones who say,
"give me the ball three seconds left.
"I want to take the shot.
"Or whoever is best to take
the shot you take the shot.
"Well we'll do all we can
to make sure that you get."
You know whatever the case
but you want that shot.
And then there are some kids you know who,
"Don't give me the ball,
don't send it to me,
"don't leave it to me I don't
want that responsibility.
"I don't want that pressure."
And an actor has to be the
type of person that says,
"Give it to me, let me try this."
Takes a chance.
You have to have a healthy dose of luck
to become successful.
That's just the way it is.
You can't you can't prepare for it
but you can be ready for
it if it does come to you.
I was very lucky to get
that role on X-Files
simply because I was
physically in the city
where it was casting.
And I was out of the city
for three weeks prior
and I very could have
easily not been in town
and they just go on and someone
else would have got the role
and who knows where I would have been.
I certainly odds are very high
that I wouldn't have gotten
Breaking Bad had I not
met Vince Gilligan before.
So it's one of those things where you you
have to just do your
wor, do the best you can
and hope for the lucky
breaks here and there.
- In magic the most
important thing to a magician
is his hands.
You know everything
that you do is based on
being able to manipulate and right.
So this type of stuff it looks
simple but it's actually me
working for a long time to figure out
how to do this stuff and it's practice
it's hours and hours
and hours of practice.
So the one thing that a magician
I think values more than
anything else is just the hands.
You're going to be the one
picking the cup so that
the fate of my hands
lies in your decisions.
Can you point to one of the four cups?
- How much is riding on this?
- Everything.
- That one.
- Yes.
(dramatic music)
- Oh.
- That was a good guess.
(dramatic music)
I saw your reaction.
(laughing)
- [Woman] Ohhh.
- But the truth is
maybe it doesn't matter
one way or another.
Like ultimately when we watch magic
the problem with this trick
is you don't want this to
really succeed because
no personal curiosity is
what would happen if that
went through the hand.
- Ohhhhhh
- See how that really looks
like it's going through the hand?
- Yeah
- And does it really
look like it's actually.
- It is yeah, oh God no.
- Oh wow.
- But there's no blood.
(screaming)
- No way!
Are you, oh God.
That is through your hand.
- There's no blood.
- Why?
It it, just pull that.
- Oh oh oh.
- Pull.
- It went through your hand.
It went through your
hand, this is not a glove.
(banging)
It doesn't retract.
Oh my God.
- Wow wow that's the
craziest thing I've ever
seen in my life obviously.
- I can't.
- You're out of your mind and most
you're just out of your minds.
In the most beautiful way possible.
My God.
- Thank you so much for
watching I made this video
because Orion Dark Knight asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
what your Bryan Cranston's
top 10 rules meant the most to you.
Leave it in the comments and
I'll join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching
and continue to believe
and I'll see you soon
(airplane flying)
(basketball bounce)
(whoosh)
- And when you're playing a guy who's
afflicted with cancer you know
the people watching the show
a lot of your audience has cancer.
- Yeah.
- Like that's just
the nature of this new
world we live in right now.
How do you play a guy like
that when you know that
there are people who
are really feeling it?
- Well the the responsibility of an actor
is to is to be truthful
in how you portray that.
So one of the one of the
simple things is I knew
that when my character
was going to go through
chemotherapy and radiation is
that he would lose his hair.
So I shaved my head.
I also knew that from personal
experience in my family
that the chemotherapy
and primarily makes you
lose your appetite and it
all tastes like metal inside
when you're going through that treatment.
And so you lose weight.
I lost 16 pounds in ten days.
- Hard to do that healthy.
- Yeah but I did it carefully.
I cut off my right leg.
(laughing)
And this is a
prosthetic right there.
- Certainly got down there yeah.
- Sixteen pounds, easy.
- Just put in a bag, put in the freezer
we can attach it later.
- So no I measured the time between
when I would have my shirt off
you know when a shower scene or something
before the weight loss
and then when I was going
to have my shirt off again
after the chemotherapy.
And it was it was 16 days oh
it's in ten days
so that I had to quickly drop that weight.
I can tell you the the the best lesson
that I've ever learned as an actor
for my career is
always follow the well-written word.
It will never fail you.
Whatever production you may be in
may not necessarily be ultimately
quote-unquote a success.
The film, role may not
be hit at the box office
but fuck that, who cares about that stuff?
It's not that's not your job
to worry about those things.
It's to focus on on that work
and it's always
about the writing.
I have I know that as
sure as I'm sitting here
when I when I decide
to do a film or a play
or whatever the first thing I
look for is the overall story.
How compelling is it?
How rich is it?
How important is it?
Will this make a social statement?
What, where in in line does
this you know rest.
The next is the text.
It's either the script or the play itself.
And they're not the same,
make the distinction
between those things because
sometimes you can have
a great story
it's just not fully realized by the the
script it just didn't quite hit it.
Or, the script was
fantastic and I didn't think
the story was going to be so good
and all of a sudden now it's clear to me.
- My question is because
I grew up in Albuquerque
what was there any cool
places anything that you liked
being there?
Like how was it because it's my hometown.
So I want to know, how'd you like it?
Or did you have fun there?
- Yeah I'd go and visit
your mother once in awhile.
(laughing and applause)